so for the very first time mr and mrs
mary fitzgerald and romaine
the season picks up right after your
wedding which also congratulations on
that
thank you um and a lot of the season is
you
trying to figure out do you even trust
your husband
relationships like need a solid
foundation
and we haven't really had a chance to
talk about the whole vegas thing
obviously i was pretty mine
[Music]
yes i really feel like
like i don't know if i can trust him
that one's tough um i i mean i obviously
trust him
he he's the most trustworthy person he's
beyond trustworthy i was just
very upset that he that he thought that
that was the right
thing to do was not tell me i knew it
wasn't his fault jason and brett caused
the whole thing and he just didn't want
to add more to my plate
i'm like you know me with lying i was
like tell me the truth and
i will not like it but i will respect
you for telling me
because i know in the future if
something happens it's out of your
control i'll know about it
you'll man up and you'll tell me so and
he understands that now
um he feels really bad and and i
i don't think he would ever cheat he's
not the kind of guy that would do that
he's just
he would just be like screw you i'm done
and then leave and then he'd go do what
he wants
he's just he's i think you guys saw on
season two and
i think he's just more vocal and just a
matter of fact
about everything he was super upfront in
season two
yeah you know what he thinks and feels
like what did he do when you met him
because there was like a mention on the
show that he was coming over to help
some like
french pastry chef or something yeah
so he when he came over um that is how i
met him
i knew his boss um or was introduced to
his boss at the time he was brought over
from ferris
as a pastry chef here you don't get paid
hardly anything
and so he was like this just isn't
working and he
got into um a project manager started
working for jason
he actually was one of the ones that
that took over jason's job
he was so good at it and so he worked
his way up through jason like very fast
and then now he's with another company
doing a bunch of our listings
um like all the remodels and new
construction and if we need
any um any jobs done prior to
to listing the home to get it kind of up
and and
looking perfect then yeah we call on him
okay wow little real estate power couple
now yeah
yeah he's working on his gc license too
so
we're gonna start flipping homes pretty
soon well we see that
thought pop up in season three you guys
can go look at a house then the
conversation turns well maybe we
actually want to live in this house
have you bought a house yet we have not
no we are we're still looking and
thinking about
what exactly we want and honestly i have
been so busy
i don't have time to do it even like i
want to do it
i just don't have time through this
whole covet thing i've been
six escrows i've got about 10 other
clients i'm trying to juggle
i just showed a 60 million dollar house
two days ago
um to a client and like it's it's insane
taking it back to what we see on season
three part of the journey you and
romaine go on to
is family planning and talking about do
we want to have a kid
do we want to freeze eggs where did you
guys land on that
that was actually supposed to be on
season three um and apparently it got
cut
we filmed a lot more and this is what
viewers don't understand we film
so much um and we don't even know what's
gonna
what's gonna be on the show so there's a
lot that goes on
um but yeah we went to a fertility
clinic
um i got everything checked and we
filmed actually
me doing all of that it just didn't make
it on the show
um yeah and then um yeah i'm good to go
i just
i haven't done the the process yet
which i i keep kicking myself for
because now i'm 40 and they said don't
go beyond 40.
but i again i haven't had time i'm
working on that
romaine has to go in and he's just as
busy as i am so we're like
we know we have to but
right now if we can't even go in to
freeze eggs should we really be bringing
a kid into this world
i mean we need to slow down and and then
decide when it's the right time but i'm
i'm going to make a point to freeze the
egg soon
or embryos actually have we upgraded the
ring from moisenite yet
yes mozart height moist at night
maybe it's like moist moisten moistenate
is naturally a curing silicone
carbide poly god knows what
and it's it's a rare mineral okay so
it's a mineral it was done a couple
months after season one stopped filming
actually
okay so yeah you've had it can i see the
the upgraded ring can you flash yeah
yeah it's a it's a
it's not clean but it's a two and a half
uh carrot
um i guess it's almost three carats with
the with all the
things around it it's a good ring yeah
thank you
all right we got to take a shift here to
talk it's not on heather christine's
level but
you know i'm i'm happy with it i love it
you